-My first guest hosts
a brand-new competition series
called "Crime Scene Kitchen,"
which premieres Wednesday,
May 26th at 9:00 p.m. on Fox.
Here is Joel McHale!
Oh.
Oh, my -- Oh, wow.
Oh! Wow. Unbelievable.
Oh, wow, wow.
Oh, welcome.
-Thank you.
-Joel, wow.
-Wow! Oh, my --
-Thank you. Oh, man.
-Joel. Oh, my goodness.
Joel, welcome. Welcome.
-[ Sighs ]
-Oh! There's a --
-Oh!
Oh, my goodness.
It's a pet of --
Joel, thank you so much.
What an entrance.
Who is that?
-Yeah.
-Who is that friend?
-I don't know.
-[ Laughs ] Oh, my gosh.
They didn't make --
-I just know
it's going to be way better
than that cat that doesn't
really play piano.
-[ Laughs ]
I thought it was perfect.
-Oh.
-Hey, get a --
See, Joel, this is --
Oh, my God.
Joel? Joel, be careful, Joel.
Be careful, now.
[ Imitates spitting ]
-Okay.
[ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Joel, we love you, buddy.
Welcome.
-Oh, oh, wait for the click.
Ahh. There it is.
-Alright.
Buddy, I follow you
on social media, and --
-Mm-hmm.
Well, Jimmy, let me tell ya --
I actually didn't freeze.
I just made that up.
-I know you did.
Joel, I thought, I thought --
You're not frozen, Joel.
Your eyes are moving, Joel.
-Oh, sorry. Sorry, okay.
-I follow you on social media,
and I want to ask you a question
'cause you do a lot of grilling
and, like, smoking.
You do like 11-hour
smoking things.
I'm going head-to-head
with Tariq soon from The Roots.
We're having
a barbecue-off competition.
I'm trying to decide
what to make.
-Oh. You're dead meat.
You've already lost.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Are you talking about
what's on the grill,
or are you talking about --
-Life? No.
Uh, you're winning.
No. Okay. So, you're going
to go up against Tariq,
and you need to out-grill him,
right?
-That's correct.
-Okay. Tariq, can I give you
a recipe to make?
'Cause I do cook a lot of meat,
'cause I was like, if the virus
isn't going to get me,
I'm going to die
of high cholesterol.
-That's very smart, Joel.
Now -- But, yeah, Tariq, can you
--
Can you earmuff? Can you just,
like, plug your ears?
-Can you earmuff?
-I mean, doesn't matter.
You can --
Give him your recipe, I guess.
I don't -- You know, cool.
-Okay, here it is.
Jimmy, do you cook at all?
-Yes, absolutely. Anything --
-Okay, good.
-Yeah, anything
in the microwave, absolutely.
-Alright, great. This is good.
You want to take a steak
and just stick it
in the microwave for 35 minutes.
It'll be fine.
-[ Laughs ] Perfect.
No, I do some cooking.
-Okay, well, then, have you
heard of the brown butter method
for a bone-in rib eye?
-No.
-Oh.
And have you heard of a comb?
[ Laughter ]
-I'm looking into the comb.
I'm looking into the comb.
Sorry, we're getting to that.
-I'll never be as cute as you,
but I want to give you this
recipe,
and you will beat Tariq with it,
I swear.
-Wow. There you go.
Do you hear that right there?
-Hello? Hello, B-Bobby Flay?
Yeah, man, I'm gonna need you to
do that thing we talked about.
-[ Laughing ] Oh, my gosh.
-Okay.
-Did you say Bobby Flay
or Bobby Fillet?
-Sorry?
-Did you say Bobby Flay
or Bobby Fillet?
-I didn't say anything.
[ Laughter ]
-I have an idea, and I think
I'm going to win this one.
What is some of the craziest
stuff you've ever eaten?
I know you're a big foodie.
-Well, I had
lamb's brain pasta one time.
Um, that was for my wedding.
And then --
[ Laughter ]
-You can have that
or the lasagna.
Yeah, lamb brains pasta.
-Uh...
-I'll go with the fish.
-The cake -- No.
But I've had cobra before.
-Maybe I could grill a cobra.
-Well, I've never done that,
and I assume "Rikki-Tikki-Tavi"
fans will be very upset.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow. Deep cut, deep cut.
You got Questlove --
-That's for everybody over 50!
-You got Questlove
with that one.
-Hey!
-What? You did.
-Yeah.
You were laughing.
-Okay, yes, I was.
-[ Laughs ]
He's like, "Eh."
-Joel, I want to ask you
about a couple things,
'cause we usually talk about
whatever your next project is,
and most recently,
it was "Card Sharks."
You're the host
of "Card Sharks."
It's returning,
so congrats on that.
-Yeah. We have actual --
actual shark contestants
this year.
So it's exciting.
-That's not true, again. No.
June 16th, 10:00 p.m. on ABC.
And that's all well and good,
but then you go, "No,
I want to take it a step up,"
and this is what I want
to talk to you about.
I'm very interested in this.
It's called
"Crime Scene Kitchen."
This is on Fox.
-Yeah.
-Now, explain
what the show is to me.
It's not a crime scene, right?
-No, no, you go
to a crime scene,
and then you eat
next to a murder victim.
-No, that's not true. No, no.
-It's terrifying.
No. Okay, it's crime scene
in that there's a kitchen,
and something was baked there,
some sort of wonderful dessert.
Skilled bakers, some trained,
some not trained, go in there,
and they just find tiny,
little pieces of evidence
like a drop of lemon
or a little bit of frosting,
and then they are like, "I got
it. It's a hummingbird cake,"
and they have two hours
to try to recreate it.
So if you like baked goods and
the thrill of solving murders,
then you are in luck.
-That's what I'm talking about.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's a show for today.
That's what I'm talking about.
-Yeah.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here is Joel McHale
in "Crime Scene Kitchen."
Take a look at this.
-I'm generally a very stoic
and put-together,
composed person.
Ooh!
But I'm also very jumpy.
I'm out of breath. This is --
-Hey, guys! What's going on?!
-Oh! Jesus Christ.
-How you doing?!
What's happening?
-Great. Really good.
-Look at this!
-We're really good.
-Are you here to distract us?
-Whoo! Yeah!
Look at all this. Okay.
-This is really helpful.
Thank you.
I have a lot of work to do,
so get out of here.
-I'll find more ways to make fun
of your turtleneck later.
-You know, I don't find myself
making fun of your outfit.
-No, but I'm
the host of the show.
-That's exactly right.
You're doing what you should do.
Joel McHale, everybody.